okay you're about to go live on youtube
um just bear with me
so yes we are now live on youtube uh
come to welcome thank you
okay thanks good morning everybody uh
welcome to this meeting of the
public engagement board um just to
uh begin with an apology that the uh the
meeting date has
uh changed a couple of times i think you
will all have been able to guess the
reason why given what has unfolded
over the past week we wanted to have
clarity um
on our messaging and at the point at
which the meeting was originally
scheduled
um we knew something that wasn't yet in
the public domain so
so we felt it sensible to um to just
just push back
um item one is attendancies and it's
just
uh attendances just to note apologies
from diane eaton
michelle hill joe gibson councillor
coggins and mandy bailey
um item two is minutes and actions from
the previous meeting i wasn't
on the um previous meeting um but
our members happy to approve those
minutes or are there any
changes or comments on those
i'm taking that as a ascent and
happiness so we will move forward um
and approve those thanks everybody and
item three is an update
on the current situation in trafford
which i propose we take with three a
and three b um and ask eleanor to give
us
um her updates if that's okay
hi sorry struggling to unmute that um so
everybody will be i'm sure aware of the
change in the situation in trafford from
um i suppose two weeks ago or ten days
ago
when we were it felt like we were
plateauing
i'm admittedly at a higher level than we
had been in
before the middle of july when we saw
that big increase
our rates dropped down to about 18 19
per hundred thousand
um and then stuck there and then
since then risen sharply and i'm really
hoping that we're starting to see them
come down again although we're still
waiting for some data so our rates are
present um from the rate
from uh friday the 21st to friday the
28th we had 86 cases which is a rate of
over 36 per hundred thousand
um so obviously this time last week
we were waiting for um a decision or an
instruction on whether or not we were
going to be coming out of lockdown by
the time the decision was made
our rates had already started to go up
um
they stayed up and obviously yesterday
the decision was made
that we should stay in lockdown
in terms of where are the infections and
why have our rates gone
up so much um the infections still
are spread over the borough but with
increasing concentrations in
three increasingly we're seeing that
concentration in three wards
um longford clifford and hail barnes
the order of those whether whose second
or third moves around a little bit
um we are not
at the moment seeing as many cases in
the west as we had been previously
but um it is a fairly spread
you know quite a big spread some
concentration as i say in the north and
the far
south and the single biggest age group
to be affected
is um the 20 to 29 year olds we're
seeing very few cases in school-aged
children
um and not and we're also not seeing
many in the over 65s although our
hospitalization rates have this week
started to go up slightly
which again is the thing that we were
really trying to avoid
um so what we've been
we have opened a new testing site in um
trafford park and that's been very well
attended
um but our positivity rate has also gone
up so it's not just that we're finding
all of the positive cases that there are
by doing more testing we're actually
identifying populations where those
rates are higher
so the increase we're seeing is i think
caused by genuine increase in prevalence
in the population
rather than being simply an artifact
that's offering more testing
and as i say the hospitalization rates
starting to increase slightly
is the one that we really want to be
making sure we we
keep an eye on and that is really the
biggest single reason why we
you know while nobody wanted to see the
restrictions
reimposed and i think everybody's
disappointed um
i do think it's the right decision at
the moment hopefully we can get these
rates down
and also i think through the work of
this board um it is absolutely about how
you
help us engage with the community so
that we can get
um we can really identify what actions
we need to be taking
to support people to manage uh manage
their lives and reduce the risk
um are there any questions on any of
that
yep can i ask
while the the cases have increased in
some parts of the borough
why is it that the whole borough is on
the lockdown
well i suppose because we are seeing
cases
across the borough it's not as if we're
seeing only cases
in one part of the borough the other
thing is that manchester
and salford also have increases in cases
and we need to be thinking about how
we fit in trafford alongside other areas
and the final reason really is that our
population doesn't stay
neatly in one part of the borough we
move around a lot
um sorry uh and
so our our population
you know especially when you think about
how people travel to get to work and so
on we've got a lot of people coming in
to work at trafford park we've got a lot
of people in traffic working in other
boroughs in greater manchester so it
really is
that we we have that interdependence as
a borough
um and it it would be very hard to work
out how we would
keep one area completely locked you know
restrictions
and not others and that's really the
reason at the moment
and the fact that we've seen that spread
across every all parts of the borough
over the last couple of weeks i think in
the last two weeks we've now seen i
think three awards that don't have any
cases but
um that's the first time that we've seen
three awards without any cases
for a little while
any other questions no
okay um eleanor were you taking us
through
um a more formalized briefing as well
um have we got that um
if i try and share anything it all
crashes out but
um the summary i mean that that's the
headlines is there anything else people
wanted
in terms of talking through the weekly
briefing because i can certainly
quickly run through that
that be helpful um
yeah i think i think maybe if we do
today and then in future if we take take
them as
read for future meetings and and and
just have any questions
then then yeah if you just briefly take
us through just because a lot's happened
this week
it has so i mean the summary of where
we've been is that we've seen that big
increase that started last
tuesday the 25th it's continued to date
although we're now
it's now dropping back down but we're
still not back down to where we
nowhere near where we were and we're
also having a little bit of a data lag
at the moment the the data
um flow seems to be a little bit slower
than it was
so part of the reason as i say is
probably because we opened a new testing
site and that may have made testing
available to people
who weren't able to access it otherwise
but because we're also seeing
more people testing positive as a ratio
our positivity rate has gone up
that is i think it's real we've got that
that issue with the north and the far
south of the borough with the highest
rates and to be honest that's one of the
other reasons why it would make it very
difficult to do a lockdown
for part of our borough when we've got
both the north
and the south of the borough and that
you know the way populations move it
would be hard to find a place that
um wasn't affected by either of those as
i say most of cases in our working age
population
and very few in our school age um
most of our testing is being done
through pillar two that's the
non-hospitalized testing most
um we are seeing a few about eight
percent of our tests are going through
our pillar two pillar one testing which
would be the hospital testing
um in terms of benchmarking against
other authorities we are
we are not currently in a we've moved
from a low
level to a higher level and a rising
rate
so again just something to be aware of
and we do need to be keeping on top of
that
um the
ethnicity uh is again
it varies quite a bit week by week and
certainly this last week most of the
case most of the
positive cases are normally in our white
population but our white population
isn't the largest
of our is also our largest population
so the relative risk varies quite a bit
by ethnicity
so we're seeing dispro we're now
starting to see disproportionate numbers
of people from vein populations testing
positive
but again that ties back into our
the populations in clifford and longford
longford wars
are also more likely to be from vain
populations so that again
starts to reflect some of the ethnicity
of the wards where we're seeing
the higher cases um most areas are seen
more women testing positive than men
we seem to be seeing more men testing
than women and especially in that
um that 20 to 29 group where we have
seen a lot of cases
and as i say there's a map with the
geographical spread and then we talk
about the 10-point plan
um which we can move on to
that's the summary of where we're up to
at the moment
okay thanks elon are there any questions
from anybody on on any
anything within that or are we okay to
move on to the
ten point plan
no okay um so item item
um four is the update on the ten point
action plan which is you again elena i
think
it is but i'm going to share this with
donna and hopefully um
i know helen and kate haven't made it um
so i've talked about the data the
10-point plan is divided into sections
and obviously the
most important thing is just give you an
update on where we are with those
sections but then be able to
spend the focus on what the actions
we're hoping you will help
us with and also your views on the
actions that we're already taking
so that we get that feedback and make
sure to show that the actions we're
doing are appropriate
so we've talked about the data and then
i'm going to hand over to donna about
the testing
thanks elena um the data shows that
we do have a slight increase now in
testing we did have
a little drop last week but we are the
top in the top four for testing in gm
and in the top nine in the country
um i think i've told colleagues before
that we have a mobile testing unit
which is in sight at trafford house and
like other boroughs sometimes our mobile
testing units are taken away to areas of
highest need
but at the moment we have the testing
unit in
trafford house all this week next week
it's going to be taken away on monday
and wednesday but for the remainder of
the week it will be
at trafford house and we're lucky that
we've been able to secure
that mobile testing unit at trafford
house throughout september
which is really positive and as elena
mentioned we
very rapidly actually were able to set
up a testing site
at trafford park and um that's
an 11 bay um walk-in site which is quite
a large site
um and we're seeing about 200 and 250 a
day
people attending that so again a popular
option
for our residents in trafford and we're
working hard to set up
another site in partington we have the
site survey
on friday and if all goes well then the
building will take place over the
weekend
and we'll be able to go live on tuesday
so a lot of community engagement in
passing to
at the moment to secure that um we also
have our testing as
colleagues know in our care homes um
and the care homes do incredibly well in
testing their stuff on a weekly basis
and their residence on a monthly basis
which is a huge undertaking
so thanks to all our colleagues and care
homes who take
that responsibility really seriously um
i'm sure you'll be aware that there's
been nationally news about the
availability of testing
sites which means um i'm really keen
that we have the permanent sites
certainly in traffic park and partington
for the next three months
because otherwise the mobile setting
units can come and go
we've also recently nationally um
schools will have a very small section
um provision of swabs so if there are
any families or children who find it
difficult to access our sites
and there'll be a small supply of swaps
available to schools
um and i think that's it in terms of our
testing program
anna do you want to cover contact
tracing as well so that people are so
sick of my voice
yeah of course so contact tracing
the local contact racing will go live on
the 9th of september
um we have apologies um we have
a number of measures that we have to put
in place before we get the go live
date but we've got an operational model
now that will be
um implemented from the 9th of september
which means that if nationally
colleagues find it difficult to contact
local residents then we can take that
over using our local knowledge of the
area
and uh local staff to to to make sure
those contacts are made
um the contract tracing inbox is very
busy at the moment
and as you can imagine lots of questions
from schools
uh lots of questions from early years um
and each case is is you know we talk the
the stuff through what the issue is and
where the staff or
or residents need to self-isolate and
we've had a couple
of local workplaces and a couple of
hospitality suites
which we've again been given advice and
information
particularly around self-isolation to
stop the spread of the virus
so fingers crossed i t sorted staff
trained
stuff in place will be ready to go live
on the 9th of september with local
contact racing
um i'm going to suggest we move that
so the next bit is community engagement
which i think is the meat of
this meeting so if we just quickly go
run through some of the
other things that have been going on so
martin do you want to do an update on
comms
i can hear me
can you hear me okay yes
yeah so yeah yeah in terms of comms
obviously it would be you may have a
certainly a busy few days
in terms of the issues around the
potential lifting or easing of
restrictions and obviously the
the change of heart on that so that has
been
uh capcom's really busy over the last
few days so
uh in terms of getting out messaging
around that and dealing with the media
inquiries
we've continued to push the health
messages out via our social media
channels
as well in terms of the symptoms and
getting a test
uh if you do have them and as well
this week we're planning to do some work
in
partnership with our partnerships teams
in the in the local mosques
so we've got some leaflets printed in
various languages that we will be
distributing to the mosques
tomorrow and we will hopefully as well
have some of our public health team
going into the mosque
and some councillors as well to talk to
the uh to residents there so
as i said been a hectic week with comms
and again we're going to continue
obviously pushing out the uh the health
messages via all our communications
channels
so the other aspects that we've been
working on through the ten point plan
have been the work with the hospitality
sector
and businesses and some of that's been
um
proactive work so and preventative work
so that's with the our environmental
health officers and information officers
making sure that businesses
understand what covert security means
and how to manage that in their
workplaces
and the other parts has been more
reactive and that's when we've had
a notification of any outbreaks in uh in
either in a business or linked to a
business
where we've then been um again working
really closely with our
environmental health team and licensing
team
and they have been going into the
businesses and giving advice
and and that's been invaluable because
quite often when they actually go into
the site
they'll see things that perhaps people
haven't um reported
or when you see something in practice it
perhaps doesn't meet the standards that
there's been perhaps a misunderstanding
of some of the standards
and i think the biggest aspect there um
and donald
um makes makes this point very well is
really making sure
that where we have had if we have had a
case in a business
or or whatever of whatever sort that we
can be confident that that business has
learnt from it
because we are seeing what you know in a
lot of the cases particularly in
nurseries and so
we're seeing really quick um turn around
in what they do and how they practice
when they when they're you know
something happens
and then um and then you say well
actually if you did it this way
this might be a safer way to operate you
know you they really do engage with it
well
and are very very keen and we're not
quite seeing that with all of
every sector i would say at the moment
so i think there is some work we need to
be doing
perhaps with some particular sectors to
make sure that they really do understand
what the
um what the rules are and why the rules
matter
um and why they matter for them as a
business as well
um the other two other pieces were three
other big pieces of work before we get
onto the public engagement
um work is the ccg are contacting
everybody who was
so the shielding has stopped and we now
have two categories of people clinically
extremely vulnerable and clinically
vulnerable
and those groups of people particularly
the clinically extremely vulnerable
are being given additional advice and
support through the ccg
and have been contacted by gps um
in terms of the clinically vulnerable
and that
includes people such as um pregnant
women in their third trimester of
pregnancy
um who you know a lot of them obviously
have understandable questions
about whether or not they can now return
to work so with most of those
groups it's a question of a risk
assessment for them
about how they can get back to work
safely and whether they can whether
their work
is conducive to safe working practice
often that will
um depend on other factors
other health factors that that has that
for example in that case that individual
woman has
so a pregnant woman who's had a normal
healthy pregnancy
will be obviously at much lower risk
than a woman who perhaps has had
developed gestational diabetes or high
blood pressure during her pregnancy
so again these will all be individually
based assessments
based on on the advice of that woman's
clinician
and her work um the other aspect we
continue to work on the infection
control
um offering training to um training has
been
carried out in all care homes we're now
rolling up that out to home care
providers
um really important we get our home care
providers um
engaged in the infection control
training when you think about where
people going
um ppe more generally um laura is our
world expert on ppe is there anything
particular laura um
that the group needs to know about i
mean just you know generally we kind of
keep on top of all the changes in the
public health england guidance in terms
of where
um recommended use of ppe changes and
we're moving towards kind of more
sessional use so making sure that we
keep abreast of
of all of the changes and we're linked
into our commissioners who are linked
into our providers to make sure that
they're
using ppe correctly and
developing kind of bespoke guidance so
our health and safety team have helped
develop some guidance recently on
correct disposal because there's a lot
of complexity i think on how you
how you dispose in various different
sets of things so trying to sort of
simplify the messaging
and where we can uh we're kind of
refining the processes to make sure that
we've got easier access to
the ppe so there's a whole variety of
places that providers can kind of access
ppe
and there's a lot of complexity in the
system so just trying to refine those
and be really really
clear about where where access can can
can happen
from i think that's that's mostly it
really it's kind of an
an ongoing ensuring that we've got the
adequate supply
managing our relationship with with gm
who are now responsible for provision of
of ppe
um and on the procurement side and just
working with with um
voluntary sector and with all of the
providers to make sure that they are
stocked up and they've got adequate
supplies
and they're aware of of guidance and
changes
and then the final bit before we get
into what can what can this board
help with is um the school's work so
we've been doing a lot
of work with the schools with their
teachers obviously schools were open
all the way through from march through
till the end of the summer holidays
until the um start of the summer
holidays so the schools have a lot of
experience
in managing the risks related to hobit
they've put a lot of really good
practices in place we've provided
guidance with given sports sessions to
schools um
and we've had q and a sessions with head
teachers with cenkos
and with others so um we're very
confident that the schools can go back
safely
the risk from primary school children is
very low both of them catching and of
them
transmitting cobit so i think we're all
very excited very pleased to see the
schools going back and really needing
just to do everything we can
make sure people have the confidence in
that sector and that we give them the
support they need
so that that's the end of the 10-point
plan but what we've put together is um
some suggestions of things under the
10-point plan so we've got a shared
action plan
between the health protection board and
this board
and laura has who's incredibly good with
uh spreadsheets and excel thank goodness
um is has put together a set of
proposals of things within the ten point
plan
that we feel that this board will be
particularly able to support
um so i don't know whether people want
to
have has everybody had a chance to have
a look at that
um andrew do you want to lead people
through that discussion or shall i
um i'll leave it with you eleanor i mean
obviously some of them
are more specific than others but i know
we're looking to get
um you know people against them where
possible
so um yeah
and everybody's had the excel sheet
haven't they
they should do i mean i can try sharing
my screen
has it has has everybody seen it the
excel sheet
it's it's in the it's in the papers
isn't it fabio alert is in the papers
i can i can try to share it for you can
you try and share it that would be great
is it helpful if i talk through what
i've tried to do in terms of explaining
where things are okay so so if
everybody's got it in front of them so
the first tab which is our kind of
overall action plan is essentially the
word document i think you reviewed at
the last meeting
um and we have tried to essentially be
really clear about
what our kind of completion criteria or
what the measurable outcome
attached to that action is um and clear
about what date we're going to deliver
those by and who's leading it and
what we need to do and we're kind of
using that first tab the overall action
plan
as our kind of weekly progress updates
to make sure that the health protection
boards and yourself have got assurance
that those actions are
in place um the second
tab i don't know which version you've
got if there is a second tab which is
called enhanced action
planning is that the version that people
can see
no okay is there just a second tab
called peb
escalations actions
laura i i think you know people can only
see
uh the very first tab one paint ten
point
escalation and point plan detail
action okay so you've got so you've got
a kind of an extract then from from the
master tab so
essentially what what we've tried to do
here is go through the the the kind of
the master ten point plan action plan
and have a look at some
specific areas where we think that you
could sort of help
support through additional activity and
so
what i've done in the first instance are
these what you can see there
are um a number of actions that we said
that we would deliver during the first
three weeks of this
six week action plan essentially um
and we will continue to sort of go
through through week on week and pull
out
additional elements um so so you can see
there the detail of the 10-point plan so
the first one is talking about is there
any
ways that we could that you could help
support us address that differential
impact
and that we're seeing in the north of
the borough and in
in different communities within within
trafford
so within the plan we've got eight eight
areas that we feel that this board would
and i'm really hoping this will now be
an open discussion where people have
suggestions who we link into and how who
can help us take this forward
so the first one is thinking about the
um
how do we address the differential
impact on on individuals and
communities in trafford and i suppose
what we've got within that is we've got
two populations
who are likely to be particularly badly
hit in
any outbreak or further spread of
um covert one is people with unserious
underlying health conditions and the
other is people over
70 75 so it really is how do we make
sure that we've got the right engagement
and the right messages to those people
that enable them to live as good and as
normal in life as possible
while protecting themselves against
covet so who would be the right people
to
and then so that's those are two groups
the other groups where we're seeing
higher cases are obviously in this
younger working age population the sort
of 18 to 35 year olds
and what's the messaging and who's doing
work with those people
and how do we get the right the right
messages to those people how do we get
the engagement
that group is likely to see themselves
as people who will not be seriously ill
if they get coded but obviously um to
some of them that
that may not be the case and also it's
the risk of spread from that population
into a
wider or more vulnerable population and
the final group will be our bain
population because we are seeing
over-representation of those groups
in in particularly in our black
bangladeshi and pakistani populations
in terms of serious illness and
consequences from
um yogurt 19 potentially because
of all sorts of structural issues such
as more likely to be doing face-to-face
work
more likely to be employed in the care
sector or in in other face-to-face
employment such as
taxi driving um more likely to be living
in more crowded accommodation
and less likely to be able to be
other aspects to do with deprivation in
that population
where it means that things like
self-isolation become more difficult for
that
for that group so it's harder harder to
get that engagement
um so though that i suppose is the
question
to this group now is how do we
who should be who should we be working
with and who is volunteering to help us
lead some of this work
some of which which is already going on
from the perspective
of the sort of message into um
older populations the age well board is
really sort of looking to
pick this up so we could we can help on
that one i hope
okay so if we if we ask the age world
board to pick that action up
um around older people and potentially
some of the shielding issues louise will
also come in there
yeah i would also be able to i mean
obviously people are thinking about
the fame issues with that older
population as well
so one of the things that um
i am involved with an organization
called calm
camera it can be an african health
network and we have been having
regular uh covered meetings particularly
by
by a zoo and it's usually every other
friday
and that is to communicate all of the
public health messages
and what we're finding is we are getting
a lot of um
even older people bain people on there
young and old
um through that forum we are
communicating with youth groups as well
so social media is really really
important i would also suggest for the
bain groups as well that
we make connections with some of the
local churches
in trafford as well as well as the
mosque so
if we can engage with the ministers
locally
that would be a massive help because
although not people not going into
churches
churches are finding ways of
communicating and from a
religious perspective people do look up
to their pastors or ministers
within the church that's really helpful
so what what we could perhaps do outside
the meeting then um louise and dorothy
if i pick up with you
or um josh fulcher um from our community
engagement team
picks up with you so that we can
understand what the actions are and make
it make sure we've got a really clear
comms line to yourselves
and absolutely the point you make about
the local churches as well as the
mosques is really important
so i'm very happy you know we will
definitely link in for that
i just can i just make a comment on this
uh i think because you have got quite
significant
numbers of people speaking different
languages
rather as you said earlier on you're
doing some leaflets i suggest
instead of the leaflets if you do video
messages
visual messages people are more likely
to listen to those
uh from their own communities and i
think if you can link in
with those people uh you can have
i don't know through four or five
different languages from
south asia uh that will be much more
effective
than just producing leaflets
you're absolutely right and so maybe if
we could have some volunteers
if we could work with you to get some
volunteers to do some messaging in
different languages
because then we could put them on the
council website and we could also send
them around as video links
to churches and to mosques and so on i
know the mosques have
agreed already to use their some of
their transmission channels
for that um i think what we need though
is that range of voices and maybe if we
can start thinking about who's
who's giving some of these messages i
don't know louise with the age well
board as well whether there's anybody
from that board who would be
um and actually i'm really sorry uh
heather isn't on the call today from
healthwatch because i know they're
really enthusiastic about doing some of
this
yeah eleanor i'm just thinking as well
dr gogar who's been doing some
well-being seminars would
be great um as well because he's been
sort of
giving lots of messages around you know
mental health physical well-being
um so yeah and we can take that to the
a12 board
because we are looking for sort of
voices and role models if you like
we've also had um some of the equalities
officers as engagement officers
within within nhs giving direct messages
via video to a lot of our community to
reinforce the message
we've also had dr ngozi from mft who's
been giving regular updates and uh
talks to assure people about the safety
of actually going into hospitals etc
so people recognize um and respect
information from people that look like
them so just absolutely
a message so um can outside this meeting
then
shall i pick up with um if we asked josh
and martin and tracy who's on the call
um
to work together with louise dorothy and
khan to try and put together both what
we know already and then make sure we've
got that
that link in what we've got already um
get it all coordinated make sure
we know where everything is and then
increase the number of links into say
the council website and other set other
places
because i mean the council puts quite a
bit we can put tweets out to link people
to
videos and so on as well does that sound
yeah yeah that's brilliant thank you
very much
so the next action sorry
michael wanted to come in counseling oh
sorry sorry
uh yeah i was just i'm not not been
involved with them but i know the
existence of the
trafford interfaith steering group
um and i wondered if that if you're
looking to to get in touch with various
religious groupings um you know
uh at once then they might be something
a group to uh
to speak to um andrew may know more
about them than me
but uh yeah i think josh is already
involved with them so we'll definitely
pick that up because i think that
i think it from the sounds that there's
lots going on but what we haven't done
very well i think yet
is maybe should make sure that we've
coordinated it understood where it all
is and make sure that ever it's
accessible to everybody because some of
these
as you say the different messages will
the more different voices we have
giving the same messages the more likely
it is that it will speak to
everybody in the borough at some point
um the next action
was on is there anything else on that
one that's been
incredibly helpful certainly sorry thank
you sorry elena it's caroline from gmp
thanks thanks for the invite to the
meeting um i think it'd be worth
reaffirming and a piece of work for
richard and i with licensed premises
certainly around the 20 to 29 year olds
and the importance of
the uh observing the the guidance
we've got we've rag rated our pubs
because it's not tenable to to treat all
pubs with the same
rigor but we we know where we're looking
at but i think
maybe a joint letter between gmp and the
council
um about the current threats and the the
importance of vigilance and adherence to
the
the rules i think that would be a really
good idea and also
probably off this call but maybe you and
i could catch up with which what
because i think we've we've got our own
little list emerging of places we're a
bit worried about so it'd be useful to
make sure
see to whether there was um uh how much
of an overlap there was between
our concerns and yours yeah if we could
we sort something out between yourself
richard and i um a three-way call we can
take that offline
yeah so the next element
was um i've lost the
i've lost the link where is it um laura
can you remember which
can you take us through the next line
you're a mute
sorry and so the next one's around
providing further support and testing to
work places so that we kind of reduce
outbreaks so again this
this may be um
um i don't know whether debbie and
caroline um
and others this may be something that we
need to be
uh putting through to the um what's it
called the
economic growth it's an econom inclusive
growth board
to make sure that that board i wonder
whether we could ask for an agenda item
there because that's to make sure that
we're getting the right messaging out to
businesses
and andrew i don't know as well the role
of the trafford partnership within this
could we take that action directly to
those those two groups do you think
certainly the partnership and there's a
meeting um place this morning actually
so
that's timely very timely would you be
able to take that action to
to that group and just see whether
they're getting the information they
need and what else they would like i
know we've
ins we've done what following some
outbreaks and so we've done quite a bit
of work with some businesses in trafford
park
particularly around agency the role of
agency workers
and also materials in um eastern
european languages i think we've
done some translations into romanian
czech
and polish is that right donna um
but again it's just making sure with i
think it's the conversation with some of
the businesses
who employ a lot of agency workers
and so they don't actually direct to
directly employ the people themselves
and
those people can quite often work in a
lot of different businesses
so we just need to make sure that the
businesses where they're working
remember um that that that practice
brings some risks and how they
how they manage those risks and and
address those risks
yeah and i think you know and if they
need advice and support we've got the
information officers we've got the
public health team other people who can
give advice and support on this
but um it would be great if we could if
the
if they're not aware of the advice and
support or if they're not aware of the
issues
it'll be really helpful to have that
conversation about what what sort of
messaging would they like from us
and what what would make sense to them
um so that we
don't have too many more outbreaks elena
i can pop a note for sue wright as well
who
oversees the um inclusive growth board
she looks after that board so i can pop
a note to her and ask her
written a gender item on there brilliant
thank you very much indeed louise that's
fantastic
so anything else on that one for now
very conscious of time
laura where are we next
so so the next one's around supporting
the clinically vulnerable and whether
there's
anything that we can do to help support
um those three
people in terms of the additional
support that's available to them for
food fuel medication etc
i think maybe for this one this would be
one where i'd be really interested
in the views of khan and dorothy
um louise from the um and tracy from the
age well board about what what's the
messaging and so on and has
has the messages that there is support
available got through to different
communities
i would say i think the message is
getting through is that the shielding is
over
and there are no there's the the support
is ending
and people are thinking it's all coming
to an end so i'm really pleased to hear
that that support within traffic is
still available and maybe
we should be highlighting that so
particularly for the clinically uh
vulnerable
i mean sadly it's not the same level of
sport as it was but there is still
support
so tracy and debbie because debbie again
your district nursing teams will be
working with a lot of these people won't
they
is there anything that we can use the
district nursing workforce
to um to to make sure those messages go
out and then tracy
again it's that that links with the um
with gp messaging and so on
yeah absolutely um any of our um
therapies as well they're also visiting
the
um you know those that are vulnerable so
any messaging that you want us
to provide you know if you have a script
or you have leaflets or anything you
want
us to take in and or what's available
we're more than happy to do that
we can pass that through all our
community services
that include social workers as well do
you think we could ask for
a lead from district nursing and social
work to work with us because they'll be
the people who've heard from the people
they're working with about what their
concerns are so we can make sure that we
get the messaging not the messaging we
think we they need to hear
but also what are the concerns could so
could we we ask you to nominate a leader
yeah that's fine i'll send you those
names and then um you can
directly you know link with them that's
fantastic thank you
and dorothy if we maybe link with
yourself as well and
um louise and the hwell board and um
anne-marie from
agents then i'm sure we'll have people
um tracy is there anything else from a
ccp point that we can
um add to that yes so the ccg have been
um text messaging
text messaging their patients and we
have had some
complaints around that some patients are
confused about the
mixed messaging around that but i think
it's been mostly positive that people
have received and really welcome that
from again a trusted source the other
thing we can do
is promote the um the support as well
with the gp
practices so that when they're talking
with the patients if there is that
information and if the patient does need
the extra support that the gp can let
them know about it as well
so we can do that in the clinical
briefings as well
fantastic because the community hubs are
continuing and i know joe gibson i think
has sent apologies to this but
again um andrew i wonder whether this is
something that we could um
ask the councillors or for all members
if we can
once we um once we clear about the
messaging if we could ask all them
make sure that all of our elected
members
know what the offer is and are able to
promote it
um that that would be really helpful to
get and i know a lot of the counselors
are already concerned about this
can i just ask a question is the leaflet
does it tell
people enough about what it is and what
people how people can get the support
has it been tested that people do
understand it
which leaflet the one about the
community hubs and the community support
i'm not sure i'll i'll pick that up as
an action with joe gibson
um and ask her to we'll we'll link
if we link joe in with the work that um
yourselves and the social workers
district nurses do i think that will
make sure that we get
all of that properly um make sure that
messaging works
can i just say um that the point you
just raised debbie about
the leaflets is a good one because i
don't actually recall seeing any of them
where how do we see them
and where are they coming from
where i'm not sure is if these are
leaflets or whether it's a link to the
website so again i'll pick that up
we'll pick that up with joe gibson
outside the meeting
and see what what's been produced yeah
because we talked about in the in the
health protection board they talked
about
education putting leaflets in the school
bags didn't they for family
and giving message in that way well you
know we're more than happy to you know
support
um anything that you want us to do
really eleanor
that's fantastic okay well we'll i'll
pick up with joe what
what has gone out and make sure that if
it is just things links on the website
that we've got a more effective way as
well as that to get people to understand
where to look
hey eleanor it's tracy um i just think
it would be really good i think you've
i think we've already said that we will
have that meeting beforehand he's trying
to capture what we have done
yeah and a lot of it verbally but it's
not being captured and written down i
think it would be really really
important for us to do that
so i think the group that you've
suggested with myself josh
and a few other people and i think they
that would be one of the main tasks to
try and capture what we are doing
then what we're planning to do and
actually how we're achieving that as
well
i think that's essential so we'll we'll
pick that up outside this meeting and
make sure
that we get that link in and we've got
so many voluntary groups in in trafford
who could help so
um and the loss is going on but i think
it's not as you say
not well coordinated um laura
next one
um just conscious of time do you want to
there's there's quite a few more and i
don't know is there other
stuff on the agenda that you need to
i think this is this is the main guess
making sure that we understand who's
doing what and how we're linking in and
getting the voices back in
for me was the main um purpose andrew is
that okay with you
here we are um
so the other ones we've got the local
businesses we've got reaching out for
additional support um the ppe i think we
can pick up
separately because um we have good
methods of linking into that
um the testing ones i think that
i think for me the the tech you know
thinking about how we promote testing in
different populations
and we are definitely seeing some
populations who think that
covid is a hoax um and
that it's um or that you can even get
covid by going to be tested
so i think there is something about how
do we you know without i don't want to
reinforce false messaging because quite
often by
mentioning the full stretches you end up
with people believing them
um but it was just really to think about
what does this group do
know about the testing whether people
feel confident about going for tests
and whether we need if you like a user
engagement group or a population
engagement group
to support donna's work around testing
and donna do you want to
i don't know what would be helpful from
your point of view
thanks helena i think um one of the key
issues is we we haven't got the level of
insight
that we need to understand why people
are choosing not to come to testing
so we can make assumptions but because
we haven't got that real
and i'm hoping that um the work that
josh is doing is going to help us with
that
i've seen quite a lot of now new
national um
comms and publicity around testing which
is taking quite a different view and
it's taking a a kind of aspirational we
need to get back to normal so in order
to get back to normal make sure you're
healthy and keep tested
so i just think you know we've got to
look at what's happening nationally but
also get that local insight
into why people because we assumed at
first it was because
people couldn't access the sites so
we've made sites more local
but obviously it's just trying to find
out a bit more about the reasons why
people choosing not to go to testing if
they're feeling unwell
i think a lot as well it is promoting
that message about um
especially if we've got any difficulties
with access to testing
we really do need to focus on getting
anybody who's symptomatic tested
and that's got to be our key making sure
everybody who's got symptoms gets tested
because we know we definitely know that
the transmission from
the precept the difficulty is the
pre-symptomatic phase and the
symptomatic
people are more infectious than the
people who remain
completely asymptomatic seems to be the
evidence
so it is really trying to make sure that
all the symptomatic people
are are captured
i don't know if anyone has any comments
or or any fro
any any insights from local communities
about
um about the testing and people's
concerns about that
i think the concerns about testing is if
that if you are in one of those groups
that are is on a low income uh you don't
have a supportive employer
then um even with the government saying
they're going to give an extra 182
pounds a week
it's not going to be enough to feed your
family and therefore
um that's where people will not be
accessing
the tests
again if we can get the more evidence we
can get around
about that the better it makes a case
that we will be put
you know the people are making that case
centrally but people are then being a
given
given the challenge about evidence it
but it's
always quite hard to evidence a negative
one particularly when
when you suspect people haven't been
given names as contact you know to the
contact tracers because they don't want
to put people in that situation
um again once we start doing the local
contact racing we may be able to find
more we may be able to get more of that
sort of more anecdotal information
tied it tied in but it again if there
are any insights
um that people have on on the testing
and
the acceptability of the offers and so
on you know we've also had messages back
that the
home testing is while it's very
accessible it's actually very difficult
to complete that home testing the the
instructions are hard
um probably
worth saying as well and eleanor and i
know you're aware of this traffic house
is
currently starting to get a bit of a
reputation as a slightly
chaotic testing center so i know we're
working with them to to sort that out
but we need people's experiences
obviously to be really positive when i
went for a test a couple of months ago
at the airport it was really straight
forward
i was in and out in a few minutes it was
done for me no problems but obviously
um you know we need to try and make sure
that that that is the norm and i know
that's not in our direct control that
traffic health facility but
um it's really important that we've got
positive and
ambassadors for the testing process you
know who experienced it
so i i you know that that would just be
one thing that i think we need to
um you know look at from a con's
perspective
um i did some stuff at the time around
how easy it was to get the test how
quick how straightforward and that it
actually went down really well in
coverage terms yeah
again we absolutely we can pick that up
and um donna you're feeding back aren't
you into the center
um i've definitely fed that back yeah
definitely it's
trafford house is slightly smaller site
than the ua 92
so i think that was one of the
challenges in that but definitely
we've been yeah pushing that back yeah
we don't want that reputation
[Music]
i'm aware it's ten o'clock i feel that
we've got some actions from this
andrew is there anything else you would
like people to um
make sure that we're we're doing or
anything that we're missing
any major tasks that you feel we're
missing um i i'm comfortable but
michael's got his hand up so if we just
just
hear michael's contribution just in case
that leads to anything else that we need
to pick up
i'm just wondering if there's anything
more we need to be doing to encourage um
temperature monitoring um amongst uh
local organizations and
and businesses you know as a way of
feeding people into the testing program
um
obviously you know with these handheld
temperature reading devices
um if we can you know if we if we can
normally normalize that process
um more so the more people are having
their temperature checked
and then obviously with with backup if
you know an obvious path for people to
take if their temperature is above
and the difficulty with some of that is
the accuracy of the test
of that and also of course people are
infectious before they're symptomatic
but i mean it's not obviously it's not
going to do anyone
any harm to have their temperature taken
but sometimes um
obviously you could still be we don't
it's a bit like some of the face
coverings we don't want people to do
things
instead it's as well so if you have your
temperature checked and it's normal that
doesn't mean you're not incubating it
doesn't mean you don't need to stay
two meters away from people and i think
sometimes that can be quite
quite difficult for people to understand
um
you know that that mix of messaging but
um we can certainly look into it
yeah the the evidence for its
effectiveness is not
it's not huge at the moment um
if it's something i've said and said
michael sorry
sorry certainly certainly it might work
lost michael there i think yes
um but yeah certainly if it's something
that we can um
you know we'll certainly look into it
because if
i sit back i got kicked out for some
somehow um yeah certainly at my
workplace you know we
we we go in we we we gel our hands and
then we
you know the first thing we do is when
we when we enter the workplace is have
our temperature
taken or to take our temperature with a
hat with a handheld
thing and it's um you know i think it's
a
it's a it's a good sort of entry
entry-level check and you know we have
picked up a couple of people who have
you know had
if you've had a temperature not realized
and you know and then you can
deal with it so it's yeah no absolutely
it's an additional it's an additional
security measure and it's a reminder
isn't it
it's just making sure people use it as a
reminder of needing to do everything
else rather than
instead of doing everything else
so okay so
um i think that probably covers the the
things that that we need to
to pick up and and eleanor's um
captured those i suppose one thing that
we do just just need to think
think about as um as has been put in the
chat is the next meeting because
currently that's scheduled for monday
so um i think even
even in these um interesting times with
our eights that that's probably a little
bit too
soon and we'd have one in two weeks
after that anyway
um would people feel comfortable if we
if we
missed monday's meeting and and then
picked up two weeks after
or did people want an incremental
meeting um
you know perhaps around the 14th i i
would i would recommend that we hold off
until the 21st and we can
obviously you know get in touch with
each other in between if needed
uh we will need to roll those traces
saying that um
the health and social constant
engagement strategy through
so um that would need to be on the
agenda for that but are people
comfortable with the 21st
yeah that's fine yeah okay we can
um i think if we also pick up with some
of the people who weren't able to be on
the call today
because i think there's quite a few
people who want to contribute different
parts so we'll that gives us a chance to
catch up with them and make sure all of
that's up to speed as well
okay brilliant well that's been
a really useful meeting in terms of
getting some some next steps agreeing
particularly
messaging out into the community which
is going to be so important after
a confusing week to say the least and
with everything that's going on with our
rights so thanks very much
um everybody that was really helpful and
i will see you all on the
21st